can you give advice to young folks today
high school college thinking about
how to make their own trajectory how to
make their own way through life that
they can be proud of either career
or just
love life
or life yeah well not necessarily on on
careers but i can give advice on
on the mating you know and i i think
it's one of these things where
um you know we have
requirements in
for the courses that students have to
take in high school for example and i
think there should be a required course
on relationships on on mating
so not just sex
yeah not not not sex at all yeah because
i mean most of what's taught is that
they teach you about sexual health and
how not to get an sti and so forth yeah
my my teacher uh put a condom on a
banana right right but
very excited but um how how to select a
maid um how do you know if you're in a
bad mating relationship uh how to how to
get out of a you know uh a bad mating
relationship um i think that
uh that there's at this point in the
science even though there's a lot that
we don't know we know enough to at least
provide some heuristics or general guide
guidelines to
things to watch out for so just as a
concrete example
uh with intimate partner violence
and this is male to female
there are statistical predictors of is
this guy
does he have an increased probability of
beating you up
and there are things like if he starts
to insist on knowing where you are at
all times if he starts cutting off your
relationships with your friends and your
family
um
so there are these kind of early warning
signs and i think women should know
about those
or even things like um
that women are most in danger of being
killed by an ex during the first three
to six months after they've broken up
with him
you know that that sometimes they think
it's you know the guy will say
meet with me one one last time and then
i won't bother you again
um no this is a dangerous time so i
think there's some knowledge
that we do know that can be used to make
informed decisions about our mating
lives and i think that should be taught
so consider that
like take that the the the mating
strategies the main the mating life
seriously
yeah yeah absolutely and uh because um
you know aside from
a small number of people who are totally
uninterested in any kind of mating
or sexuality and there are small
percentage that fall into that category
um we all confront problems of mating
how do you you know there's that uh um
called the mathematical model like
secretary problem marriage problem i
don't know if you're familiar but
basically you have a it's it's a silly
perhaps not uh it's a formalized
simplified
queueing theory type of thing where it's
you have and and subjects and
you get to date some number of
um
people
and then there's a stopping condition i
believe it's n over e
beyond which you pick the next partner
which is better than anybody you've
dated before so
uh yeah let's not over emphasize that
idea but
um
if i were to psychologize it i would say
that
some exploration is good
some dating is good but at a certain
point you pick somebody given the set of
people you've explored
you pick somebody
who is uh
pretty desirable within that group yeah
yeah but i would add that what you also
want to do is you want to
um
mate with someone who's equivalent in
mate value
or or has even what's more difficult is
has a
likely
equivalent future mate value trajectory
because nothing remains static yes uh as
beautiful
but it's also the case that there are
individual things we haven't talked
about these with things like um
religious
orientation political orientation
values these are extremely important to
be compatible on and so you do have
cases of let's say
a democrat marrying a republican uh
and that sometimes works but you're
going to get into a lot of conflict
other things being equal or someone
who's um deeply religious versus someone
who is not all religious this is going
to be a problem or someone who's of a
different religious faith
um and and so
uh compatibility on those things
compatibility also on personality
dimensions i think there's some main
effects like so i would i would
recommend avoiding that dimension we
talked about of emotional instability
because
if you sign up for that you at least
should know you're going to be in for a
lot of conflict
it may be exciting at times but there's
going to be a lot of ups and downs know
what you sign up for what about how much
to date
so there's a culture
i'm
speaking soon to a founder and
long-time ex-ceo of tinder
so there's that culture of digitalized
dating of swipe right swipe left
uh
is it positive negative how much did you
date
yeah what's the number and also
what number of sexual partners should
you what's optimal asking for a friend i
don't know if there's a single uh
optimum there
um let's hope
i i think is it
is it single digits or double digits i
need answers well i don't know i get
some of my wisdom from lyrics from uh
songs so um
uh
this evil song i think don henley you
know said something like a there are too
many lovers in one lifetime ain't good
for you or
something like that yeah but um
you know
i think there there is a
take it easy is a good one too yeah or
uh
basically don't don't get don't get too
attached don't take it don't take
heartbreak too seriously
yeah so but but i think i mean you know
internet dating and you know there's
there's been some work on them i think
has its pluses and minuses you know i
and one of the pluses is it gives you
access to potential pools of mates that
you could never possibly meet in real
life you know where mating and dating
used to be either people you knew or
friends of friends or you go out to bars
or parties but so that's the good thing
gives you access to those
extended pools but also it gives people
the um illusion that there's always
someone better out there for you someone
who's just a little more attractive a
little more compatible a little more and
so
it produces what's sometimes called
decision paralysis
you know you have too many options and
you you can't choose i think one one
other
potential um
negative which i think could be
corrected by these internet dating sites
is that the
picture the photographs
uh the of the of the face and body tend
to overwhelm all other sources of
information and so especially if you're
if you're just looking for a sex partner
that's one thing physical
appearance is it's fine for that to be
overwhelmingly important but if you're
looking for a long-term mate there's so
many other things that are really really
important
and so
but but people tend to be
uh swamped by the
visual input which is natural because
that's where we've evolved to respond to
visual input we're not
you've ought to respond to words
you know like uh oh i'm
i like to go fishing or something like
that uh so if there's some way for these
sites to
in long-term mating for
these other characteristics to be made
more salient in people's information
processing i think that would be a
valuable uh improvement yeah because
even
forget long-term beauty even sex appeal
is is
um like even the word appearance
it feels like to me people that are
super sexy in real life
are a lot more than their picture yeah
yeah like
it's actually surprising like they come
to life in different ways yes it could
be either submissiveness of shyness or
ex extravagant
um wit and humor
or like uh super confident or super like
whatever they are the whatever the
weirdness that they are comes through
immediate so when people say well
that which is the case of the uh of sort
of proponents of dating apps it's like
when you meet somebody at a bar you're
getting the same experience as you do on
a dating site you have very little
information all you get is appearance
but i don't think
appearance on the screen is the same as
appearance in real life yeah especially
with people that for some reason you
find super sexy because like and again
the objectification that we mentioned
earlier is the
the um
it over optimizes for people who are
good at taking pictures of themselves
like they're representing themselves
inaccurately
they're
not just even in the physical features
but in the way those physical features
are used in physical reality
like in terms of body language in terms
of flirtation in terms of just
everything everything put together so i
just um there i i wonder if there's a
way to close that
to close that gap
and i don't know what that is exactly i
tend to believe more information is good
on dating i think i don't use actually
dating apps i just because
they don't make any sense to me because
there's not enough information
like what this like uh
to me
like whether you know dostoevsky you're
not as important
and i don't mean that because you've
read specifically a book by dostoevsky
but there's something about
have you suffered have you thought about
life deeply have you been shaken in some
way
and that's not sometimes books can
reveal that sometimes something else can
reveal that but this got a
very shallow resume like i like to
travel
i have boobs all right it's like this
kind of thing is it loses the humanity
of it all yeah i want because listen as
a fan of technology i would love
dating to open up like you said the pool
of possibilities out there the soulmate
idea like i believe that there's an
incredible people out there for you that
is an emotional connection not just a
physical connection and so that the
promise of um
digital tech is that you can discover
those people and that's not just for
romantic relationship it's for
friendships it's for business partners
it's for all that kind of stuff like
your your friend groups
but yeah there's something seems broken
about dating sites yeah well that's why
i mean
when i'm asked for advice on this i say
if you feel like you have a connection
with someone
meet them in person you meet them in in
real life because the road trip be like
yeah because there's only i mean
so much you can learn through
messaging and so forth